Hello, everyone.  We will now begin Part 1 of the
Chesley Morning Brief for a happy investment journey
on Friday, June 26
.
Oh, it's a fun Friday weekend.
First, let's hear from Manager Wang about how the Chinese market performed on that Thursday before the weekend
. Yes. [Clears throat]
Lately, while tech stocks have been strong, stocks have
risen by 23%.  The Heungseong Index saw
Wennus drop 1.5%, while Jeongsi Geodae
maintained the 3.5 trillion level.  If
you look at the sectors, yesterday we learned that the communication, consumer goods, and IT sectors were
weak, while the consumer goods,
energy, and DT sectors were weak
. Looking at the IT and communication sectors, the
IT sector
rose 4.7% yesterday.  And in the
communication sector, it rose by 3.7%
.  Looking at Yeongyang Elementary School, the IT
sector has risen by 99% compared to Yeongyang Elementary School
.   The
communication sector surged by about 72%
.   I
searched for IT-related stocks yesterday regarding global IT sector synchronization and capacity expansion.  Bobang Hwacheon rose 3.5%,
Joytech rose 9.9%,
Jongsa rose
2%, and Jeonjeon Tech rose 10%; all
require a new historical report.  The Bobang
Hwacheon just went over 100 trillion yesterday as a model
.
It's 74% from the beginning.
This time, driven by expectations of earnings, the Friday
market surged, and the Kwangdong Shin Kwon-ryeong Jodo also
showed strength.  Copper 5,000, inflammation 9%,
renal function 9.9%, 9%, natural dryness
5% have gone up.
Yesterday's stock market was conceptualized by a massive recovery in regular trading and high expectations
.  Central Securities rose by 4%, and the
Dongmang tip-off went up by 5%.
CCR prices are currently seeing additional price increases
.  Probably next week, that
King Boat company already handled some funeral services the day before the branch this month, you know
.  You know what
I said about 15%.   It is
laminate
.  that's right.  There is a
possibility of a 10% to 15% increase next week
.  So, we need to look into next week then
.  So yesterday,
CC and PCP Kwon Yong-ju both
surged.  Approval Tech rose to 5.5%, younger
sibling's rating to 73%, and improvement caution to 8%
.
Oh, in terms of the cooking style, the Kwon Young side continues to
skyrocket.  The Chinese one is
9.2%.  Take it off.
When Puni first researched that, it was already established
rather than the foundation at that time.
Oh, Jongjae Tech has gone up 10%, and Gujeol
Buje has gone up 5% recently.
Following the surge in MLCG prices,
MLCG-related stocks remained strong yesterday as well
.  The Sunma Jeong
rose by nearly 13%.  Pokhwa Tech
hit the 10% upper limit.  Yogahara,
and the Yuan, Jeolseondeung, Heo Jae-in, and Hwangju
were forcibly seen yesterday as well.  Chunggu
rose by 6.3%, heating requests by 3%, and Chunggu Dongbang by 7%.  On the other hand,
energy organic bower stocks dropped a bit.
Oh, the new salt concrete interest rate is
7bp yesterday.  The specific interest rate of ideological assets
rose by 1.4 pp bp, and the foreign exchange
rate was reduced by 2%.
thank you
yes.  Uh, our manager told us yesterday to be
careful when starting a business, but the startup market has
gone up a lot again.
Oh, my.  [Laughs]
Yes.   I
'm just kidding. When the stock market has a direction,
naturally,
there are indices with a slightly higher beta.  It seems like the startup scene is a bit like that
.  I’d like to ask a quick question regarding Chinese macros today before
moving on
.  yes.  In both the Korean and US
markets, only the stocks that are genuinely rising actually go up
.  So, in Korea as well, in severe
cases, there are times when only about 10% of the total stocks
rise—meaning the index is
increasing, but only about
10% of the stocks are actually rising. So,
[sniff] it
can be seen as rising in a highly compressed manner, centered around memory stocks, and it
seems the US is no exception.  As for China, when I
look at newspapers like this,
regarding things like semiconductor growth and technological rise, things are generally
very good, just as Director Wang introduced;
however, domestic demand is
sluggish, and the overall economy
doesn't seem to be running very well.
So, I was wondering if there were any related sports you could recommend, as
the government will likely be making a lot of effort to revitalize the economy and boost the economy in that regard
.
Ah, here is this.  Well, there are
quite a few good ones.  Well, things like the Gyuzmo Concent are
good. If
you look at it from a Gyuzmo perspective, the Hood Pier currently has
no 17x rice.   It's
just that MC Maju has a 50% stake, right? It's a
company that can come out, and it's continuously buying back its own shares and
strengthening its position on the main screen. A
company like Sensent is, well, right now, a
company that needs to raise and spend money, isn't it?  However, that
11x multiple has just been released.
[Clears throat] It
is a tech company that is less than ten times larger.  Companies like this are all
being marginalized.  So,
I think there is a possibility that such companies could rise significantly once the semiconductor cycle stabilizes and the Chinese economy recovers.   I will
wait and see if the sectors or stocks receiving excessive attention become too expensive, or if a turnaround signal emerges from the opposite direction
.  yes.
It seems like a company I've seen before.  Large foot
laser.   yes
.  The Daecho Laser Company
made that announcement once last month.
At that time, the company's stock price surged by about 70%
.  It surged 70% in less than a month
.  The global laser
equipment casting is just maintaining 1st place with MS 9% charge, and it
is Global 300.   If
you look at the composition of support sales, PCB
costs account for 30%, pre-capital increase equipment for 13%,
and other lasers for about 95%
.  Compared to the agreement that generated sales in No. 1, it
surged by about 12% compared to the agreement ranked 74%.  At that time, it
comes out to be double the market budget.  The GP
participation rate is about 34%, and the MP participation rate is
about 8.5% and 5%, and all agreements
have been withdrawn.  The
reason for the [snorting] [clearing throat] is that the score continues to be good due to two factors: the massive PCB equipment business
unit and the recovery of the maintenance business unit following the second suspension of capital increase
.  Revenue from the PCB maintenance business unit surged in the first quarter
. This unit's GP is coming out at around 33%
.  These days, all those PCB-
related companies are doing well, you know
.  The die company needs to use maintenance
.  So, this equipment is
causing a Stige situation.  Uh, originally,
the level from January to May
was 150% compared to the same period.
Compared to January, orders in April
are about 90% of the same period last year.
So, this has
been extended by up to 150% for one month. Even if
you purchase now, you can receive the full amount by the end of 2027
.  So, this Shootchi
trade name continues to be planted.   The
City Central Office report
came out the day before yesterday.  It came out yesterday.  We issued a buy recommendation due to the
expanding demand for Apple service payments in PCB gun modules
.  1. In
the case of the PCB market, the volume of
PCB and rights receiver-related
equipment is increasing due to the upward adjustment.  And we have
also entered the Apple replacement cycle.
Originally, the first phone was scheduled to be released, and next year was the
iPhone's 20th anniversary.  So you can
look forward to that new upgrade
.  Therefore, regarding sales in the coming
year, the price was adjusted by 1% to
2% relative to the designated price, and rose by approximately 1% to 3%
.
As the equipment entered a bull cycle, Take
rose from 49x to 55x.   I
suggested around 177.  It is
up 14% compared to the previous time.  The two-year
EPS CGR is 44% and the
PG is 1.600.   hmm.  yes
.
Right now, if you look at equipment stocks from a PG
perspective, they are all roughly
viewing them at 1.6 to 2 times.  So, if we
can cover up to 1.6 times the overall industry average PH here, the
multiplier can roughly eliminate about 30% or
come out to about 30%.   yes
.  [Snoring]
Yes, that's what a quiz is.  [Laughs]
That's right.  yes.   yes
.  Uh, for it to double or triple, there has to be
a reason for receiving a multiple higher than the profit growth rate, and
right now, that reason
seems to be growth potential.  Of course, there may be companies that
possess an overwhelming economic moat compared to any other, or
, well, are practically non-existent, but I
think that for most companies currently trading at well over 1x their page value, it is the expectations and growth potential for their respective industries that are driving this.  Uh, it’s a
really good company, and looking at the data below,
seeing how all the multiples are hitting new highs, it seems the market is already
aware of it.   yes
.
Uh, what hints can our Chamilton members, who heard today's presentation on this stock, gleam
from the Korean market
?
Ah,
direct investment from China.   uh
.  Yes. Stay calm because you can kick this.
Because you know that first class we were talking about
.  It is a market where individual investment is
not possible at first
.
Individual investors cannot buy the stock starting from Sander, and foreign individual
investors cannot.  Our organization can
sleep.
So, this Hoja kind of starts with the hero, you know
.  This is a house where foreigners can buy
.  So I feel
comfortable.  I see that there are some regulations or things like that involved in the picker
.   yes
.  It is becoming market segmentation.   Regarding
the markets that start with Sanpoda but foreigners cannot enter,
what are the first positions?   It's
0, and it starts with profanity, and
there is one that starts from 0. Hmm,
0, 3, 6—yes, that's
correct. So,
0 allows foreigners to access it, but
3 does not, and that is
correct.  Ah, 3 is not possible, and
6 is possible.  You can't just start with 688, you
can't start with 688.   yes
.  You must not start with Yo 80.   hmm.
difficult.  [Laughs]
Anyway, judging by the fact that it starts in English, this should be fine
.
Ah, that's right.   yes
.  All right.  It seems there are no similar
companies or competitors in Korea
.  All right.   Since
there are such shining stocks in the Chinese market, I continue to promote the fact that it is possible to generate high returns using "yellow chips" and non-index-related stocks, especially for those around me who always
say that investing in stocks isn't fun,
now that there are people who look at indices
.
That is as far as we look at the Chinese market.  Let's take a look at the US market yesterday
.  I have a request for you, Yuripro
.   yes
.  I will now report on the US market that closed on the 25th
.  I
emphasized yesterday that the stock price rebounded strongly some time after Micron's earnings announcement
.  And so, it is a
market where there is no reason not to rise.  I
believe I mentioned this before. If we
look at the indices first, the S&P 500 closed flat, while the
Nasdaq ended the day with a slight decline
.   I will
tell you a little later, though.   The
weakness of the megacap was somewhat of a
reason.  Now,
if you look at the Russell 2 won, it rose by 0.7% to 7%.
However,
rather than indicating an influx of new buying interest in small and mid-cap stocks, it appears to be closer to a partial retracement following the
drop of over 2% yesterday
.  However, sentiment remains
alive; if you look at the 10-year yield chart on the right, it has
settled stably in the 4.3% range, continuing from yesterday. Also, while big
tech and mega-cap stocks were somewhat weak, the
Dow Index itself rose slightly
.  Looking at the fact that the SP 500 and Russell
held up relatively well, I would like to
first summarize the atmosphere as a market where risk appetite had not completely broken down, but there was also a lack of confidence to push the entire index up
.  So, just to
gauge the atmosphere, I’d like to start by checking the
personal consumption expenditure price index and interest rates that were announced yesterday. Yesterday, the
May personal
consumption price index, [clears throat]
personal consumption, personal income,
and the final and revised figures for Q1 GDP
were released.  Now, regarding PC prices for May, I have
summarized them in text below, but first of all, they
rose 4.1% compared to the previous year.   It
rose from the previous 3.8% and was the
highest level since 2023
.  Also,
excluding highly volatile items like energy, this is the core
PC.  Looking at my source PC here as well, it
increased by 3.4% compared to the previous year.
At the same time, the first-quarter GDP was also revised
upward, showing an annual growth rate of 2.1%
. If you
combine these indicators, I would
say that the overall picture is closer to a combination where growth is holding up, but prices remain somewhat high. Therefore,
looking only at the figures, you might be concerned that prices are rising too high.
However,
since GDP was also revised upward along with the rise in personal consumption, it
seems possible to interpret this as consumption holding up despite high prices, as both personal consumption and income are increasing.  And the
data showing this seems to be government bond
yields.  If you look at the
government bond yields listed numerically on the right, the
10-year bond closed at around 4.39%,
and there was no significant change compared to the previous day
.  It rose slightly, but the
2-year yield fell back a little to 4.13%
.  So,
looking at this combination, if we consider why the
stock market was
n't as strong as expected yesterday given that interest rates fell, it seems difficult to attribute the reason to interest
rates
. Rather, it appears the market reacted more to the fact that while the PC figure was high, it remained within the expected range, and the margin call compared to the previous day was lower than anticipated.
So, if you look at the dollar spot, it
fell by about 0.2% to 2%, but
since the decline itself was not
significant, rather than viewing it as a critical
or strong risk
indicator, you can consider it a limited dollar weakness resulting from the fact that
interest rates did not surge despite the PC coming out high
.
If you look at oil prices as well, well, as I mentioned, interest rates were
stable, but oil prices have risen a little again
.  WTI has
reached the $72 range per barrel, while Brand has
risen to the $75 to $76 level.  As expected, the background
was due to Hormuz's swimming.  There was
news yesterday that
a passing ship was struck by a US missile, and that
some Soviet and merchant ships turned
back after attempting to cross Hormu
.  So, while the
hormone market seemed to be
normalizing over the past few days, it appears
the market reacted somewhat sensitively as energy supply risks reappeared through this volume.
However, since the responsible party has not yet been
clearly identified, it is best to understand this not as a
full-scale resurgence of designated risks, but rather as a
reflection of the uncertainty regarding crude oil supply
.   yes
.  Now, please move back to the middle section, and you will
now look at the corporate group.
Now, if Micron was actually the star of the market yesterday,
today saw such a significant decline that it felt like Big Tech was the real star.
However, following Micron's earnings announcement,
expectations for rising DDR5 and NAND prices,
along with their sustainability, became more widespread. Consequently, not
only Micron but also storage-related stocks like SanDisk and
Western Digital were
strong, while
semiconductor equipment stocks such as Applied Materials and Lam Research also
performed strongly, hitting new highs.
The Philippine Index also rose by about 3.6% to 6% yesterday. Now,
returning to the question of why the index did not keep pace with individual stocks, it
seems we can confirm at the corporate level that the positive stock price news triggered by Micron failed to spread to the entire market. As I
mentioned earlier, Apple and
Microsoft showed particular weakness
.  Well,
Apple suffered quite a heavy loss, particularly falling 6.1% and 1%, while
Microsoft
dropped 3.5%.  Apple
raised the prices of its Macs, iPads, and home devices across the board yesterday following the rise in memory and storage costs.  Well, there
wasn't an official earnings announcement or a Compass Call, but it is
estimated that the reports coming out yesterday regarding the price changes on the Apple Online Store had quite a big impact.  Since the
prices of various products rose simultaneously, and it was
not just an adjustment to a few models, the reason for the surge in memory and storage
device prices has now been clearly
determined, and it appears that the
stock price reacted somewhat on the 10th
.  Microsoft actually
followed a similar trend; they
have a gaming console called the Xbox, and they
further increased the price of this console.
So, the reason
was indeed the rise in storage device and memory prices.
I mentioned on the 10th that the Xbox business unit was
scheduled to downsize its workforce.
Now, looking at this in connection with the completion of the business unit's restructuring, the
fact that the profitability of the Xbox console business is somewhat lower compared to the past has been highlighted once again, which has led to increased
margin pressure for price hikes
.  Furthermore, as
memory shifts toward data centers, PC
memory is becoming insufficient, and the burden is
being passed on to consumer hardware products. If you had only
considered this as a possibility, yesterday's
price hikes
seem to confirm this trend.   yes
.  And uh, there is a stock nearing its new high that I haven't been able to
see yet, a company called Fortinet
.  This isn't about memory or
equipment, but it was a company that was
mentioned again due to data center expansion
.  Well, the guidance from
Young Kang and the recently announced
earnings report were already somewhat positive, but
regarding that, a direct catalyst yesterday was a
report from Invest Business Daily (IBD). The
report
highlighted once again the competitiveness of the company's proprietary AC-based economy and the complementary demand resulting from the expansion of the AI ​​data sector.  So, just because this
company makes A-type chips does
n't mean they manufacture Broadcom or CPUs. The A6 chip they produce is a
security-dedicated A6 chip used in their own firewall equipment.
So, please keep that in mind
.
So, putting everything else aside, I think the only
word you need to remember here is "complementary stock." Also,
based on this data, we can use our imagination to predict how far the range of AI data centers will expand, which I
think can be confirmed by the fact that the company hit a new high.   If we
take a look at the semiconductor sector as well,
memory and equipment stocks rebounded strongly yesterday, triggered by Micron's earnings
.  Micron rose 7% to 15.7%, and in the
memory and storage sector,
SanDisk rose as much as 22%.
Now, comparing case A with Lam Research, I
thought you might be wondering why Applied Materials rose more significantly, so I gave it some thought. Since
semiconductor equipment stocks benefit from the expansion of CAPEX, the
overall
structure involves continuous factory construction. As
CAPEX flows in, I suspect the logic applied might be that
Aim benefits more overall than Lam Research, which has a portfolio specialized in etching. Notably,
TSMC was the only stock to
fall slightly.  I
looked up some news about TSMC yesterday, and I heard that there was a
technology symposium in Shanghai on June 25th
.  So, they unveiled their
own AI chip, Halla Fenual, here, and it
fits perfectly with TSMC.  With reports regarding Open AI, the
logic that demand for TSMC's process per line remains intact
was maintained; however, the
reason it fell was likely because the market's buying
point yesterday was focused on memory or equipment, as confirmed
by Micron's earnings, rather than foundries like TSMC.
Therefore, it
appears to have been relatively neglected.   It
looked like the optical illumination was recovering a bit.
Since these stocks had fallen significantly recently, it appears they are showing a retracement alongside the infrastructure recovery trend
.  So, to wrap up, yesterday the
market failed to drag the entire index despite Micron's good earnings.
However,
rather than saying it marked a shift to a bear market, as I
emphasize, it was a day where the
beneficiary stocks and the cost-burden stocks were once again divided internally
.  And
rather than saying that the Big Tech sector as a whole went up, it seems we can view this as a day where the market clearly recognized the actual bottlenecks
and the companies with price-passing power,
and that this was reflected in the issues of Apple and Microsoft raising their
prices
.   That's
all.
thank you  Whenever
you explain the US market in detail like this, I think I have a good grasp of it in my head, but when
I hear your final summary, I realize, "Ah, it was
n't perfectly organized after all." [Laughs]
Thank you always for summarizing it so well.  I don't think this is the first time Apple has dropped 6%
.  There are two people, and since the
fluctuation seems unusual, I
think it might have various implications for the market. Just like you, our
Choi Mil-tan members, wrote here, are you saying you
won't buy Apple products simply because the price has gone up
?
There are so-called Apple bars, right
They use the expression "App-fanboy."   It is
not a vote for that Apple fanboy thing.  [Laughs]
Yes.  So, for those of you who like Apple
or own honey charcoal,
yes.  I think it might be a day where you need to do some thinking
.
Let's look at the US market up to this point.  I will now move on to virtual assets
.  Mr. Junhyeok.   yes
.  I will speak about the Gaseon Market.  If
you look at the front digit now, it has been changed to a typo.
Yesterday, [clearing throat] my voice was very
bad.
With a significant drop, it showed a sharp decline from around 9 or 10 o'clock
to 11 o'clock
.
So yesterday, it dropped to about $58,000,
but it seems to have recovered a bit and is currently
trading at the $59,000 to $60,000 level
.  First of all, it seems certain that buying will come in as a rebound if the $60,000 mark is broken
.  So, I think it is certain that this zone is a strong support line, both in terms of specific
areas and as a
psychological support line that people perceive.
This is the
third attempt, and it
seems like it has rarely stayed significantly below the $60,000 level after breaking it.   It
showed signs of returning to the $60,000 range as buying pressure immediately came in, so I think we just need to
keep a close eye on how the trend continues this time
.  I
couldn't find the reason for the significant drop.  However, as issues
related to low-form strategies and
funding conditions have persisted since yesterday, it
seems that even if sentiment breaks
significantly, it will continue to be
perceived as a major negative factor, leading to large movements. Rather, because trading volume is
so low and
interest here is somewhat alienated, it
reacts strongly to even minor news, resulting in significant up-and-down
fluctuations in Bitcoin. I
think it would be best to view it this way.  Uh, if
you look at the long-term Bitcoin chart on the right, there is a reason
I brought this chart when looking at the big picture
.
That red line at the very bottom
is the 200-day moving average. I will briefly
introduce it below, but this
is the 200-week moving average.
It's the 200-week moving average.  That 200-week moving average
always showed a pattern of breaking below it and then finding support again to
rise; we
saw that once before in 2022 as well. However, what
I was trying to say is
not that it will find support at this point and go up, but that since it has broken below this level, it
no longer acts as support. Therefore, there is a
very high probability that it will fall below this point and continue to decline.  And rather than
saying that it will crawl sideways or the price will plummet, I would say that
if the
price moves sideways, or crawls sideways, or if
the price continues to be a bit boring
.  I think there is a very high
probability that it will stay hovering around the $50,000 level before finding the bottom. Since the
price trend is so bad, it
seems like they are actually trying to keep looking for positive aspects.  A
major issue needs to emerge like this,
causing a crash, in order to find the bottom we had anticipated
.  Uh,
when people keep hitting the floor, the
floor never comes.  It's just... uh,
I'm actually just
looking for the bottom, like a giyuje. I've found the bottom where a really big
issue comes out, big enough to really shock people
.  We aren't exactly hoping for that big issue as we
move forward, but
anyway, you can view it as a history of that sort. And
since the Bitcoin Peered Index is always lagging, it has settled
into the current phase, and has been
recording for about 10 days.  Uh, as of the 24th,
uh, it
seems like the update isn't quite complete yet, but about 400 million years
have been leaked.  So, you can
consider the overall trend to be very bad
.  Uh, if you look to the side,
uh, they say there is a place called Rose and Rose and Roi
.  They say they have
launched an investigation into that strategy, but it does
n't seem like this news came out exactly at the time yesterday when the market crashed
.  As the
initial news spread across various sources, it seems there
was a slightly bigger reaction last night. It is reported that the U.S.
law firm Rosen has launched an investigation into potential securities claims related to a misleading business involving A Test and founder
Michael Seller
.  [Snicker]
Since the exact details haven't been revealed, I
think we'll only know for sure once follow-up reports come out, but I believe this issue was the
main factor dragging down yesterday's decline
.  It says that Rosen is a
famous investor management law
firm that investigates potential securities fraud on behalf of shareholders, and looking at their website, it seems they
mainly focus on securities-related matters or
systemic rights
.  So, you can consider that such specialized
forms have been attached, and
attention is focused on whether Strategy and Sailor have made claims that could cause misunderstandings about the business of the company.
So, I believe there is a very high probability that they will investigate whether Stradi's current statements,
claims, or business
plans—such as raising funds through research preferred stock or selling Bitcoin to suit their interests—have caused misunderstandings and resulted in
some harm to shareholders
.  It was also mentioned that it is
difficult to view this problem solely as a strategy issue
because many imitators have emerged.  Regarding these
imitators, while
many companies like Strategy have emerged that buy and hold Bitcoin,
many companies have also appeared that actually buy Strategy's products.  So, you
can view it as those things being somewhat intricately intertwined. Since
dozens of companies, including both listed and non-listed firms, are
collecting Bitcoin before holding it like Steji, it is a
highly symbolic event in that it could have massive repercussions.  Because, for example, if we say that the
strategy has a
problem, it becomes a fact that almost all
companies following the strategy model have
problems. So, I think
that
aspect can actually be seen as symbolic.
Personally, I think that amidst the recent attacks targeting the strategy and STIC, we are currently facing a very critical phase
.  So, for example, if this
model is said to have a problem, it seems reasonable to assume that
aggressive damage will also be inflicted upon BitMine, which collects Ethereum, even though it is not directly and perfectly similar
.
So, if you look at the photo at the top left, it shows the
price trend of the Strategy STRC.  STRC is currently facing its
worst trend in history as it drops to nearly $74
.  Even when it usually went down, it typically
fell to the $80 range or, on average, to around the $90 range, and whenever that happened, it
consistently showed a pattern of raising its odds. However, now that it is at $74—
down nearly 20-something percent—and the $100
pegging has been slightly broken, it seems likely that the
weakness will continue. The
trend for the MSTR is also very bad.  It is hitting near-record lows, having
dropped to the low $90s and around the mid-$80s.  So, you can
consider the flow production to be very poor, and since
we have been aware that the flow has been bad all along,
if Strategy were to really
put on a spectacular finale, it is
difficult to fully predict how it would turn out.  I haven't really considered the possibility that Strategy would go
bankrupt or end like this,
so I
think we need to review whether that is feasible.
However, I do
not view the current situation as one where Strategy cannot hold out. As I
mentioned earlier,
companies in the surrounding sector that lack funds,
popularity, or various
institutional backing are actually at a
much greater risk than Strategy. In the
case of Strategy, major shareholders like
JPK and BlackRock are already attached to it
.  So, since it appears that such companies are
not currently selling, I
think that aspect is somewhat stable;
however, you should view it this way: companies employing various unreasonable models could be at a
significant risk
.
And
if you look at the bottom left, there have been
reports from various sources stating that it has broken below the 200-week moving average
.  Historically, even when the 200-week moving average has
dropped below the shoulder, it has
consistently shown a pattern of rebounding and rising again, and it has
reached that zone once more.  So it seemed like it would hold,
but when looking at the continued repetition of historical patterns—if
you look at the 22-year pattern—it failed to
rebound immediately after falling below the 200-day moving average
.  I think it would be fine to just keep in mind how it maintained and defended that part for quite a long time
before rebounding
.  And the
reason volatility intensified once again yesterday is that the
expiration of large-scale options is scheduled
.  Personally, I think that since the option is scheduled to expire in about 11 years,
those
factors may have had some influence as well
.  Anyway, to wrap things up, just like I
mentioned earlier, it
seems that in order for the market to truly hit rock bottom, many people are expressing it as being almost at the bottom.  It's about knee-level.  It
seems like there are a lot of people who say they have only come as far as knee-level so far.
So, even those who say that ultimately no one is like that, they were
saying things like this.  Many people say that by the time they
found the bottom—that is,
when they judged whether it was you or not—they were already on the floor, and
I share a similar
sentiment.  I am
not exactly sure if this is the bottom or not, but in
any case, sentiment is
deteriorating significantly. Earlier this year, I
mentioned that this ETF would have absolutely no effect on Bitcoin purchases, and that Strategy was actually having a huge impact on the market as the largest buyer. However, seeing that Strategy—the
sole switcher's strategy—is under
such heavy attack, I
personally think that this might conclude with a major issue triggered by this "finale strategy." I view this
aspect as very positive.
Rather than the Bitcoin market itself
improving, considering Bitcoin is currently
acting as a representative risk asset, I am starting to think that we might see a
bull market or a market
favoring riskier assets unfold in the second half of the year
.  So,
considering those aspects, I personally think the second half of the year is something to look forward to, and I
think that will wrap things up.  That's all.
thank you  You
showed me the 200-week moving average in the bottom left corner;
200 weeks is roughly 4 years
.   You could
say that this is also related to the Bitcoin halving
.
Oh, right.  yes.  So, exactly what you
said is that this cycle is every four years, and the
angle is exactly like that every four years
.  So, don't those aspects also
accurately affect the psyche?
Don't they have a psychological impact?  I think it might have a technical
impact.   hmm.  yes
.  In the stock market, reaching the "knee" usually marks the
start of staggered buying. While we
need to see how the price moves, I think it has dropped to a level where those with more interest should pay closer
attention
.  That concludes our look at virtual assets for today, and we
will wrap up Part 1.
Thank you to everyone from Chamilton who joined us, and we will see you shortly in Part 2
.  thank you
[Music]
Hello, everyone in Chamilton.  I will briefly host the
Chesley Morning Brief with the Happy Investment Fairy, and then
switch with Mr. Immediately.
Uh, yesterday we had a very clear, rough summary of the US market with our Yuri Pro, but since I
think you might have a bit more detail, I’d like to
hear it from the novice CEO.
Ah, yes.  Overall, it was a
day that showed a stark contrast between Big Tech, semiconductors, software, and IT infrastructure.  And with that
signal, as Apple raises product prices—
often referred to these days as "chipflation"—there is even talk that
the price of chips is so high it is
driving inflation. On
the other hand, it seems that these
factors have been continuously
strengthening the momentum in the semiconductor memory sector
.   In the
software sector, Panlantir fell 5.5% yesterday as well,
dropping about 40% year-to-date.
And in the case of Nerveen, it fell 33.8%,
Oracle 21.1%, and Lobby
17.4% and 4%, respectively.
This
could be due to supply and demand factors, or it could be due to concerns that companies that have been highly valued in the past may face
valuation contraction in the future
.  So, well, it is an
economy where the overall economy itself is driven by infrastructure.  And
since the investment momentum in the semiconductor sector continues, I
think this kind of polarization is occurring. Even
within the PfL index, it
seems to be splitting into sectors with stronger momentum and those with weaker momentum.  So, in
my view, regarding the future direction of the Philban index, rather than
rising as rapidly as before, I
think some differentiation will emerge within it.   The
Afford Index rose 3.6% to 6%. In the
past, when sentiment was good,
everything would have risen and the growth rates would have
been similar. However, yesterday,
particularly because Mycon Technologies
announced its earnings and momentum strengthened in that sector,
Mycon
Technologies
recorded a new high within the Afford Index.  And
SanDisk, a storage device manufacturer,
recorded a new high.
In addition to that, new highs were reached in the Applied Materials and
Teradyne equipment sectors
.  So,
about three stocks within the general index and
SanDisk, which is not part of the general index,
recorded a new high. It
seems the number of stocks hitting new highs might decrease slightly.  In my
opinion.  Therefore, companies that lack competitiveness and
cannot generate profit will be thoroughly
excluded from the general index, while
those that are profitable and capable of expanding their valuations appropriately based on competition will likely continue to see their
stock prices rise
.   It was a
day when the M7 fell miserably.
There is an equal-weighted ETF that tracks the M7 called MS, and I've
held it for a long time, so it
dropped by about 7.4%.  Well, as you are probably
aware of the Philban index, in the
case of Source, it increased by 107.6%
.  And the software sector is
still struggling a bit. A
software
ETF called IGV has fallen 19.8% after being held for a long time,
while an ETF
composed of data center infrastructure has fallen 47.25
%. So, it seems there is a
stark contrast between the M7 and Philippine indices regarding software versus data center infrastructure or hardware
. Meanwhile, in the US market, so-called old economy stocks—such as energy, necessities, industrial goods, materials, and utilities—seem to be just doing okay on the sidelines.   I
looked into the valuation following Micron's earnings announcement, and how much Micron impacted the entire Filbance group in terms of EPS, stock price, and multiples. The
stock price surged due to the earnings announcement
.  Anyway, and the EPS
estimate has also been revised upward by 13%
.  Ah, looking at the previous period,
Micron
was trading at around 10 times its earnings, but
due to the significant upward revision of its EPS yesterday, it is currently trading
at a PER of about 19.2 times
.  The recent high
was 11.2 times.  It was double.  So, just
as stock prices are rising, the
political landscape is also being adjusted upward steeply
.  So, the PR is
not as expensive as the stock price has risen.
I think you can understand it like this.   In the
case of the A-Fielban Index, Micro
was adjusted upward by about 0.8% due to the impact of earnings, and the
PR is trading at 27.7x 7x
.  Ah, the recent high was 29. Since it's at the
3x level, it's
not exactly an easy PR.
So, it seems like earnings announcements will start in July, and I
think the PR will likely be determined based on how much the EPS is revised upwards.  And regarding MoneyMull, it seems like the interest rate
levels themselves will
put pressure on companies at the peak of their PR
[clears throat]. Yesterday, the
May PC price data was released, and it
matched market expectations.
At the same time, it
seems that caution regarding prices has eased slightly; the
headline PC came out at 4.1%, and the
core PC came out at 3.4%
.   If
you look at the
energy sector,
rather than the energy sector itself, if
you look at the energy sector in May, the
energy sector
increased by 3% year-on-year from 24.3%,
so it seems that this sector had an
impact. Also,
excluding energy and housing costs, PC service prices were
3.9%, which is quite sticky
.  So, if
we face inflationary pressure in the future, I
think that rather than the rise in energy prices due to oil prices, the inflationary pressure in the service sector will have an impact on overall prices.  So I
think we need to look closely at this part, and
I expect inflationary pressure caused by energy prices to pick out in May
.  So, looking at
FedWatch's market reaction to these inflation announcements, it appears that the
hawkish sentiment has subsided somewhat.
The
reason is that,
considering the rate hike freeze on June 18, the
FMC is holding another meeting on July 29, and they
assessed the probability of a freeze at that time at 61.5%.  Looking at it now, it has
gone up a bit to 67.9%.  And,
around June 18, the
market consensus was for about two interest rate hikes this year, but
now it has
dropped a bit to about once.  And it seems that the probability itself is also
heading towards a slight increase.
I think I need to keep checking this.  It seems it would be a bit difficult to do a unit in the current situation
.
So, the headline source PC has
turned out this way, and while it is currently high, I
think the headline source might remain a bit sticky. Looking at gasoline prices, they
peaked in May and
came down a bit in June
.  So, it seems this will
affect the overall headline price easing
.  Also, the
Cleveland Institute estimates PC and
CPI prices, and
coincidentally, the
FMC is being
held on July 29th.  The PC
announcement is on June, and the PC announcement is on July 30th
.  So, regarding the FMCS, it
seems the Federal Reserve will not be able to see the June PC and will proceed with the meeting.  The headline PC currently estimated by the Cleveland Institute is
4.1%, based on what was released in May.   We are
reporting that June will drop by 0.2% to 3.9%, and
core PCs will remain the same at 3.4%
.  And I think we will
check the CPI before proceeding,
because the June CPI is announced on July 14th.  We expect the CPI to fall by about 0.2 to 2 percentage points
from 4.2% to
3.96% in May, and
as for the CO2 CPI, we
expect it to drop slightly from 2.9% to 2.85%, but we
anticipate it will remain at almost the same level.  Based on this, it
seems difficult to conclude that the Fed will drastically raise interest rates on July 29.
So, just based on the
fact that they are picking out the headliners,
I think there is a high possibility of a freeze
. Hmm
.  The finalized Q1 GDP figures have been
released, and the implications we can see here are that,
from an investment perspective, private corporate investment is currently driving U.S. GDP. We need to
examine whether that trend continues. If so, I
believe that companies with a competitive edge in areas such as facility investment or equipment investment can continue to maintain momentum. The
finalized figure for GDP was 2.1%, whereas the
preliminary figure was originally 1.6%.   In the
case of PC, there were preliminary, provisional, and
final figures. Now that the final figures have
been released, the 0.5% to 5% point
increase is attributed to a
slight decrease in import value, which
boosted the first-quarter GDP
.  As for the rest, if
you look at the ratio next to it, U.S. consumption itself
accounts for about 70% of GDP, but the
ratio itself is quite low.   It
was low in the first quarter.
Rather, the investment sector is in a situation where it is hovering in the low 1% range.
Roughly speaking, the
composition of US GDP is about
70% for consumption, 20% for private investment, 20% for
government spending, and
-10% for net exports, totaling around
100%. Therefore, the fact that
private investment—which accounts for 20% of the total—is taking
such a large opportunity suggests that we can
estimate that the scale of growth is appearing very steeply
.  Uh, looking at the
chart by content below, regarding the non-residential investment
sector,
the residential side
represents IT equipment, AI servers, semiconductors, and data center hardware. If we
look at the trends, the Q1,
Q2, Q3, Q4, and Q1 of 2022
contributed about 1%, and the next
contributed about 0.2% to 0.4%, but this time, Q1
contributed 0.88%, or 88%
.  So, we can see that this side is
expanding quite steeply, as
confirmed by the GDP and the growth rate by text
.  If
you look at the quarterly trend on the side of the requiment, you
can confirm once again here that the angle is appearing quite steep
.  So, one application we can derive from this
is that the
stock prices of companies representative of the semiconductor equipment sector—such as Applied Materials, Lam Research, ASML, KL, and Teradyne—are actually moving in tandem with the steep increase in
spending on equipment as a percentage of GDP. For instance,
Applied Materials and
Lam Research have risen by about 130 to 160% this year,
ASML by
72%, and KLA and Teradyne have
increased by around 100 to 140%.
While the growth rate is slightly
lower, there is a company in the construction and power sector with the
ticker symbol PWR, which
is a sequence service.   It
is the largest power infrastructure construction and maintenance company in the United States.  Well, I have
n't done detailed research, but
conceptually speaking, it seems that momentum in the
construction power sector is being maintained as investment in such equipment increases.
Also, Quanta services have risen 70% this year
.  Caterpillar is a heavy equipment
construction company, a heavy equipment manufacturing and
sales company, and it also rose by 84% in this sector
.  It is a well-known company with a G number, the
global No. 1 operator in the gas turbine sector, and it has
risen by 66%.  While the
growth rate might be slightly lower than in the memory or semiconductor equipment sectors, I
think it can be considered to have the momentum to continue rising steadily.   That's
all.
thank you  Today, just like usual, you are
showing us data processed in your own unique way that can't be seen anywhere else, so yes, oh, that's
good.
[Laughs]
Thank you. Yes, yes.  I learned a lot today. I plan to
review the table below again later and ask a few
questions. It
seems like you analyzed it just like you would analyze import and export statistics in Korea.
yes.  That is correct.
yes.
Looking at the table you showed regarding the 30 stocks of the Philadelphia Semiconductor Index above, this is just
my guess, but from Nvidia to the very
bottom,
aren't you perhaps listing them in order of their weight within the index?  It's pretty similar.  They are almost
similar, but one thing to note is that
TSMC is listed via ADR.
Therefore,
the proportion of that side in the Philban index itself ranks about 16th
.  Because the Philban index is based
on the proportion of floating viewership.
So, many people think that if SK
Hynix is ​​included in the Filipino Index, it will
have a tremendous impact, but
in reality,
when considering the free-float weighting, Hynix's
influence on the Filipino Index is
not that significant.  Um, just so you know
.  Yes, then, since the
Philippine Index is also an index, it will probably be
rebalanced regularly.
However, due to these changes in market capitalization, for example, I'm
not sure when the next one is.
When rebalancing, will the
weight of Micro increase significantly and
change accordingly?
yes.  That's right.  That's right.  It doesn't change.  Of
course, I think that will change.
SanDisk might join now, or rather,
SanDisk... ah,
SanDisk isn't currently on the general index. I'm not entirely sure
why this company couldn't be included in the general index,
but ah, they recently
spun off from Westile in 2025, didn't they?  It
was spun off, and it is somewhat grouped
with Wesson or C-Gate in a similar vein.
Although it is a bit far-fetched, based on what I
found on CHAPPY, it is
closer to a storage device than a pure semiconductor,
so it does
not fit the nature of semiconductors.
yes.  People say that their personalities don't match, but in my opinion, it would
n't be a problem at all for SanDisk to be included in the Philbanjusu group.
Anyway, well, it hasn't been long since it was spun off, and since it is
classified as a storage device, I don't
know if it fits the nature of a standard index, but yes, it is
true that it is having a significant impact on the NASDAQ and the SP 500.  hmm.
Micron could also see its weight rise again
.
yes.  I think it's currently ranked around 4th in the Philban Index
.   yes
.
All right.
Uh, and next, you pointed out the price indicators.
First of all,
which page is it?
June 18th and June 25th.
Is the page with the table on page 2 or page 3?   It's
page 3, right?  yes.  Since you
showed me this, anyway,
because stock market valuations become a bit tight when interest rates rise,
yes.
Uh, it's not a good thing, but
Uh, what if they raise interest rates much faster than expected
?  I was thinking this way, but
based on Rodetta, you
mentioned that inflation indicators could come out slightly lower than or equal to market expectations, so the timing of an interest rate hike might be pushed back a bit compared to what I currently think. Thanks to your remarks, I feel
a bit more at ease now.
Uh, we just used a little bit of imagination.
Yes, the
monthly PC indicators
are above.  yes.
Uh, if the Middle East-related
issues are resolved well, at least
energy-related companies will
continue to move in the negative direction.
Uh, so if,
yes, the
prices, uh, the prices we are looking at right now
are around 4% as you can see here,
yes.
Uh, if it shows a 6-month to 1-year journey from 4% to 3.5%,
yes.  Then, Vice President, do you think we
can't lower interest rates, but should we just keep them frozen
?  How about this?  Ah, I
think I will go while freezing
.
Because, um,
so, ah, so, regarding what influences prices
, there are supply factors and
demanders, you know.  So,
when a supply shock occurs from the supply side
, the easiest thing to think of is the
meat sector.  When there is a shock to oil prices,
it will likely
stimulate inflation and interest rates
.  And
speaking of demand factors, there is inflation driven by demand when the economy is very strong, you know
.  It seems like that
could stimulate prices and interest rates, but
currently, the supply factors themselves
are easing somewhat.  Looking at the demand side itself
in yesterday's GDP, the
proportion of consumption in the U.S. is
very large, but the contribution of consumption to GDP is
decreasing significantly.
And right now,
private investment in AI infrastructure is
driving GDP growth, isn't it?
So, regarding
demand-driven inflation, if consumption,
investment, government spending, and
exports are all strong, prices could be
driven by demand to unexpected levels. However, since the only
strong factor currently is private investment,
I believe that demand-driven
inflation will be somewhat
limited.   In
that case, actually, even if interest rates rise,
stock prices would be better, which is really good.
yes.  That is correct.  So, I
think that if supply factors ease somewhat and demand is held steady by private investment rather than the entire economy, inflation will likely be limited. In that case, I think the rate of increase will just
continue to fluctuate around
4%, 4.4%, or
4%.
However, for it to
break through the 4% mark,
oil prices would have to drop sharply due to some factor,
or
the economy would have to deteriorate significantly due to some factor, but it
seems difficult to assume such extreme situations in the current circumstances.
thank you  Uh, I remember it was last year, last September
.  Goldman Sachs coined the term "postmodern cycle" for the period
following the pandemic—specifically from 2022 until
now—and discussed
what kind of investments we should make in a situation where interest rates are not falling as expected and valuations always appear to be saturated. Although I did
not quote the exact text mentioned by the Busan Director, it
seems likely that there will be concentrated investment in the direction the overall market is moving.  So, I
mentioned last September to the interns at Global Insights' Earth Platform that it seems we are entering an era where the expected
return from selecting specific sectors or stocks is far more important than the expected return from investing in an index. I also said that while this has already started to some extent, it seems we are entering a time where there are many alpha opportunities if you pick stocks in AI-related sectors, such as IT hardware and semiconductors, as well as surrounding infrastructure-related traditional sectors. I recall sharing this with
them last September, and an
update regarding that was
released on June 16th.  I'll
probably be going out this weekend to match the filming schedule
.
Uh, the content is similar,
but I have summarized the Golden Awards’
opinion—not my own—regarding the progress made so far and what needs to be done from now on. I
think it will be very helpful for the interns to look at this.  I promoted it.
So, then, to get straight to the point,
what do they say we need to do starting now?   I told you I'm
going out on Sunday.  [Laughs]
Ugh, I'm in a hurry.  [Laughs]
Yes.  Uh, well, to briefly summarize the conclusion,
yes.
Uh, don't get off in advance.
Yes, in that sense.  With that purpose in mind, various raw
data, examples, and messages are being provided
.   If you
have been doing it that way until now,
do it exactly as you have.  That kind of story.   yes
.  yes.
Stop nagging me and
look at their [laughter].
yes.  All right.
Finally, yes.  I clearly
remember
looking at this table regarding the Cleveland Fed estimates.
Several years ago, early in our Morning Brief, around the time of the
FOMC meeting, we used to report on the CPI beforehand...
Oh, I apologize.  That over there, right?  The
Fed reports on TPI, but
PC misses the report and holds the meeting due to a difference of a few days
.
But I
really wonder if they don't know. It is a government agency, after all.
We were talking about how it was only the second or third day, so we thought they would unofficially know everything before the FOMC meeting. I
remember the Vice President giving us feedback at the time, saying, "But it really seems like the U.S. is holding the meeting without knowing."
So it
seems like a really developed country.  Uh, is it still like that
?
Well, I can't know for sure
[laughs], but I guess I have to
believe it.  yes.
So, as you estimated, if we hold a
meeting after fully examining PCE inflation, the opinion that interest rates need to be raised might
become softer. I
think that is also a key point to consider
.
Yes, thank you for organizing that valuable material so well today. I also
asked various questions about things I was curious about and didn't have any hints about.  Let's leave the US market
here and
move on to the domestic market.   Mr.
Oh, I have a request.   yes
.  I will speak about the exclusive market.   The
KOSPI closed with a gain of about 5%
.  The KOSDAQ closed down in the 2% range
.  In terms of supply and demand,
individual investors
showed signs of taking action worth about 2.4 trillion won, while foreign investors have
maintained their selling trend day after day
.  There was also a sale of about 800 million won yesterday
.  Institutional
buying pressure reached approximately 3.3 trillion won.
[Snicker] There
was a sell order of about 2.8 trillion won in the main futures.
Also, as the market neared its end, selling pressure
expanded significantly.  It was like that the day before yesterday, and
yesterday
was a similar video.
Looking at trading trends by investor type, foreign
investors bought LS Holdings, LG
Innotek, Alteogen, LG Electronics, Seoshin,
Seojin Systems, and others yesterday.   On
the other hand, regarding sales, approximately
3.6 trillion won worth of SK Hynix was sold, and in addition, SK
Square Electronics, Electronics preferred stock, Hyundai Motor,
Samsung Electro-Mechanics, etc. were sold.   During
the period, Samsung Electronics purchased nearly 1 trillion
won worth of shares.  And I
bought about 900 million won worth of SK Hynix.  Other than that, I bought Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
Alteogen,
Samsung Electronics preferred stock, Samsung C&T, Lino, etc.
In the period sell,
only ETFs
are visible, just like the day before yesterday.   yes
.
Uh, it has become a market dominated by ETFs
.  Uh, well, I
always feel it. When we
have lunch, if we have an appointment, we take
a moment before eating to check the
flow of things.
Actually, since we
eat quickly—like finishing within 20 or 30 minutes—when we look back, everything has
changed drastically.  You are probably
having that experience a lot these days.
People say they feel dizzy while eating. It
’s not like just watching the screen guarantees the answer, but if you don’t, you
can’t predict the trend well, so there is a
constant sense of anxiety.
Now, how are you managing your investments these days, Doctor Gwang
?  How
do you check your mindset?  As you said, it is dizzying every day for now,
but in a situation like this, Sol,
you are actually constantly swinging between extremes
.  yes.
Yes, they say only the stocks that are going up keep going up, and so on.   In
times like these, stocks that rise on a daily basis
actually do so for a reason.
Conversely,
among those that fail to rise, we need to distinguish whether they are
unable to climb because their earnings have genuinely collapsed.   yes
.  So, if that is the case, I
think we could also consider a replacement sale.  But
[clears throat] it’s not like that. The real
performance figures—uh, it seems like the second, third, and next year’s
results haven’t been broken—
so actually, we are in a
situation where we have to hold onto it again.  So, personally, I think we need to keep
checking our portfolio to some extent in that way, and that we need to stay
focused
.  yes.  When we manage investments, we find that with
individual funds—especially
when individuals manage their own capital—they can hold out as long as their
faith in the stock and their investment
assumptions remain intact. However, for
institutional investors, due to stop-
loss regulations and
rules regarding relative valuation over time, there are
actually many cases where they are forced to trade even though they know they shouldn't sell or buy at that moment.   hmm.
Besides, that’s because it’s the end of the quarter and the end of the
half-year.
Aren't those kinds of transactions becoming even more extreme?   I end up
trying a little more.  So, especially in
times like this, if the reasons you
carefully checked the stocks you hold do
not waver, isn't it necessary to be a little more
patient
?  I find myself wondering if being patient is actually a form of
flexibility
.   I
think I need to study [laughs] rather than just having determination and patience.  Of
course, I think that patience needs to be
based on study. If you
keep falling into those bad cases unconditionally, the
common mistake people make
is involuntary long-term investment.  So, there are
times when you tend to turn a blind eye, and that is a very difficult
phase. I
believe that the courage to admit your mistakes or errors, reflect on them, and change them is needed even more than patience. If things go well, you
need the courage to keep going; but if they do
n't, you need to
take another look at the actual problem. If you realize you really misjudged it,
rather than setting up scenarios or assumptions like "I should sell it if I don't know," or "I should sell it if things go wrong," I
think it is right to take immediate action when the fault or mistake is discovered or recognized.
Hmm, that's right.  I have mentioned this
a few times when talking about large foreign pension fund investors
.  Uh, there is a
big difference between maintaining a portfolio by doing nothing and doing nothing after all sorts of sincere deliberation.
That is correct.
yes.  You can't just sit still.
yes.  To give a simple example, let's say I should have
bought stock A, but I mistakenly
bought stock B instead.  But
a little while later, I confirmed that mistake
.  Ah, but uh, regardless of the
direction of the stock price, I
think I need to get it right now.
Uh, the stock I bought has
dropped a lot, so uh, since it has
fallen so much, I thought I should
wait until it goes up before buying.  Ah, I should sell it.
Or, since A turned out this way, I should
wait a bit before buying this.  I
actually
think this is a case where they are making a bit of a bad move.  So
[clears throat] uh, if
I made a mistake or a fault and misjudged the direction a bit, then it is
correct that there is absolutely no edition, just like the title of that book by Isedo.  It is correct to set up three boards
.  Actually, that
contributes to future achievements and leads to improvements; I
don't think we should view simply holding out based on a scenario or false hope as patience.   I'm telling you, no
.  I
told you it wasn't.  yes.  I will do it.   I’ll cross my arms and
stop talking about the [laughter] now, and let’s look at the major stocks
.   yes
.  I didn't mention the 52-week report. Oh
dear.  yes.   yes
.  On the KOSPI, Samsung Electronics preferred stock
and SK Holdings' SK preferred stock hit
new highs.  On the KOSDAQ, Gigavis and
Gwangjin Industries hit new highs.
So recently,
among the semiconductor or IT equipment companies on KOSDAQ, Gigavis seems to be quite solid
.   Due to
relatively high stock price volatility, the stock has been
continuously
hitting new highs recently
.  yes.  Looking at the major stocks, I will start with the
semiconductor sector.
Samsung Electronics closed up about 5% yesterday, and SK
Hynix's
stock price surged about 13% due to the strong performance of Micron
.  And if you
look at the materials, parts, and equipment sector below, Reno
closed with an increase of about 4%.  Jusung
Engineering closed
with a significant drop of about 8.5% to 5% without any particular issues
.
Stocks like Jusung and HPSP have been receiving a lot of attention recently, but it
feels like they are dropping to some extent.  This was especially true for HPSP; even
though Terra had
n't even started yet, the
stock price rose by about 50 to 60 percent in the short term due to news that equipment would be installed there
.  So, it
can be seen as a phase where those issues are being resolved. The
market closed up by about 7%, and it
seems there were some positive reports released yesterday.
And if we look at the IT sector, Samsung
Electro-Mechanics closed up about 1.7%
.  Recently, it seems that the upward
momentum itself is slowing down a bit
.  And
BH closed down about 7%.   The
platform sector
showed a somewhat sluggish trend compared to the market, with Naver and Kakao fluctuating fairly evenly, while the
Nikkei index
closed yesterday with a 4.6% surge.  Oh, the
semiconductor sector was definitely good.  Tokyo
Electron closed with sharp gains of 7.8% and 8%, and
Murata and Ibiden, which can be seen as peers of Samsung Electro-Mechanics, also surged by about 7%,
showing a somewhat
differentiated trend in the electrification sector.
Advan Test also closed with a 15% surge
.
If you look at the automotive sector, Hyundai Motor
closed yesterday with a decline in the 1% range
.
Uh, since it has dropped to the level of ten times the PL, I
think it is worth paying attention to this section.  The consumer goods
sector was weak in terms of large-cap stocks.  The trend for small and
medium-sized enterprises below was also generally sluggish
.  On the other hand, the market for Pio beauty
devices is a bit mixed these days.
It seems like they are going up one after another.
Classys recorded a significant rise of 2.3% and Pharma of about 6%, while in the
food sector below, Nongshim remained flat and
Nam Foods
closed with a rise of about 1.9%.
And the department store chain below
was quite good.  I don't think it's
accurate to view department stores as semiconductor-related stocks these days
.  Yes, because if stock prices rise significantly due to semiconductors, it stimulates
consumer spending
.  Rational logic is actually
showing results.
How can I not agree if you want my consent with that kind of look
?  [Laughs] It's
not a matter of agreement, it's reality.   yes
.  [Laughs]
Yes.  If you take a closer look at the shipbuilding and steel sectors,
shipbuilding stocks generally closed lower yesterday
.  The chemical and steel industries continue to face somewhat
uninteresting situations
.  And recently,
as oil prices have fallen significantly, S has
shifted to a weaker trend.
Yesterday, the stock prices of Gangsan stocks were very sluggish without any particular issues
.
Dry Nex 1 came out this morning,
before the market opened—well, actually, about 30 minutes ago
.   We
announced a plan for a paid-in capital increase of about 500 million won
.   hmm.   uh
.  yes.  I checked the public disclosure, but the specific
reason for that is
n't listed.  Uh, I think the 102 Kepa is a bit
lacking.  So,
regarding that, I suspect the capital increase was done to expand the facility. While we will have to
wait and see how the stock price moves, I think it would be better to view this as positive news rather than negative
.  And Rotem,
Jusa, Yotem, and
Hana showed weakness on this side.  It seems like it has dropped significantly because Rotem has fallen by 17 times
.  In the biotech sector, large-cap
biotech companies showed a decent trend yesterday.   The
KOSDAQ bio sector was a bit
sluggish.  Petron
also saw a sharp drop of about 16%
.  It's not here, but Liga Bio also
had some issues this morning.   It
seems that the National Listed Fund has attracted some investment towards Rigaken Bio.
It seems like they are entering the market together with Orion. I
understand that Orion has also made some bio investments in the past, so
there is a new news article stating that Orion and the Gomin Growth Fund are investing together.
And as for securities stocks, Kiwoom Securities
surged by about 7% yesterday, showing a rebound after its
stock price had been quite poor recently
.   It
seems the entertainment sector is still a bit out of its mind. FabV has fallen 3%, and with the
rest of the entertainment stocks
dropping as well, it is a
very attractive situation from a valuation perspective, but the
market conditions
don't seem very favorable.  It doesn't seem
easy to resolve the concentration on direct investment stocks, so for
long-term investors, if you look at
heavily accumulated defense stocks like Hyundai Rotem
or investment products during this phase, I
think it could yield profits in one or two years.  The transformer sector
was weak, except for Hyundai 1. Yes,
thank you.  Looking at the left side, specifically regarding the broad definition of
hardware and IT—such as semiconductors, materials, parts, and equipment—the materials, parts, and equipment
sector has undergone significant correction recently. With the
exception of a few companies, it
seems that the 50x, 60x, and 70x valuations I saw a few weeks or months ago are no longer accurate; they have all
come down considerably.
When looking at the stocks shown here, only Hanmi Semiconductor, Jusung
Engineering, and Samsung Electro-Mechanics still have notably high
valuations, while the rest appear to have
dropped to levels we saw in the past
.  Uh, and regarding the stocks on the right, if we
look at them all the way down from the top, uh, Hyundai Motor, uh, we do need to
look at things like whether they are cyclical or various uh, business models and competitive relationships with rivals, but roughly speaking, it
seems like there are a lot of stocks that have dropped below 1x.  So, if
there are any stocks that catch your eye like that, I think it would be a good idea to focus on
those stocks when your portfolio is diversified. Even
though foreigners are selling heavily, buying interest is currently
concentrated on the top two semiconductor stocks and their surrounding stocks. I
believe it is correct to continue monitoring this with increasing weight as time goes on to see when this will unwind.  yes.   I will
understand it that way and move on
.  Uh, you brought two more
reports today. The first one is from
Hamari Research;
what is the title of this commercial?   yes
.  yes.  yes.
Uh, let's listen to the Kiwoom Securities commercial
.   yes
.  This is material from Researcher Park Jong-hyun of Daul
.   They say there is
no time to explain.
So they say we have to get on quickly, but I
think there was something similar to this last year as well.  Now that the stock price has
started to drop significantly, this is an
opportunity for
PharmaResearch.   yes yes
.
Well, like Perma and Samyeong Foods, there were quite a few
titles of that kind
.   hmm.
First, looking at the details, it was projected that
investments in US brands and marketing, along with
growth in the cosmetics sector, could lead to sales exceeding market expectations
.
However, while OPM may decline slightly due to marketing investments, I am
somewhat looking forward to a recovery through operating leverage.  We set the
fair value of the stock at 540,000 won due to upward revisions in estimates
.  Here
are the comments on the Q2 earnings.  With sales in the 175 billion won range and
operating profit of 67 billion won, it was estimated that
both profit and sales
would increase by more than double digits year-on-year or QQ
.  Therefore, based on sales, the
forecast is that operating profit will likely meet the consensus.  The medical device division is
projected to reach 64.6 billion, an increase of about 6% year-on-year and 11% quarter-on-quarter
.  With procedures becoming faster before the medical strike in the second quarter of last year, I look forward to seeing
Yi demonstrate growth despite the underlying average
.  With
medical tourism spending on dermatology in April and May reaching
140.8 billion and 145.2 billion won, respectively, marking all-time
highs with 60% and 80% growth year-on-year, it
was predicted that the upward trend in spending on dermatology due to the Japan effect and the domestic wealth effect would likely be maintained.  It is judged that the company
can maintain its market share despite the competitive atmosphere
.  The existing expansion of sales growth will
be maintained.  So, medical device
exports are projected to reach around 26.7 billion
.  With YY showing around 10% and Q around 26%, I
predicted that there might be some expansion in the upward direction as well.   The
cosmetics sector is also doing very well, with
estimated sales of around 18 billion won.
With YY at 60% and Kiosk at 18%,
the outlook is that the cosmetics sector may also see some high-growth market conditions.  And they say they are expecting an
increase in B2C duty-free sales due to the influx of inbound tourists
.  The outlook is that the
increase in HB channel sales contributed to earnings growth
.   They say they
expect high growth of 105% year-on-year and 49% quarter-on-quarter, with exports reaching around 40 billion.  I predicted that there would likely be an
upward trend in sales across Southeast, Europe, and Eastern Europe channels, and that
sales growth would follow the effects of Cellora's entry into the US and China stores and channel expansion
.
Looking at the export data, it is estimated that exports in April, May, and
May grew by 69% and 64% year-on-year, respectively
.   We
expect the GPM to reach 75.6 due to changes in the number of mixes resulting from the increased proportion of cosmetics
.  Therefore, we currently estimate that the
OPM will decrease slightly due to the increase in labor and advertising costs
.  It is said that rapid growth is occurring
in the cosmetics sector based on the Liz brand.
Although the outlook forecasts a decline in OPM due to marketing, we
expect a gradual improvement in OPM driven by operating leverage.   It
seems like they raised the target price a little.  Yes. Do you happen to
have anything to explain about the table below as well?   yes
.  Growth in the medical device sector is
estimated to reach about 17% year-on-year this year
.  Since the pharmaceutical sector accounts for such a small
portion,
I think we can skip it, but I expect the cosmetics sector to maintain high growth
.   It
seems that it is estimated to record a significant growth rate of about 60% this year, following 70% last year.  So, in the
cosmetics sector, both AP and Pharma
Search are doing quite well in North America right now, are
n't they?  But
anyway, the medical device sector is still somewhat
important, so it seems a bit disappointing that the growth rate itself was
low last year
.  So, actually,
the numbers themselves aren't bad for domestic demand, but it seems the market
continues to be skeptical about it
.  I
can't quite remember the name, but I think the stock prices are showing signs of concern regarding the entry of competitors,
such as LNC Bio.  On
the right is the
amount of skin care spending by foreign medical tourists in May
.  Since a
large number of foreigners are continuously entering the country, and in particular, the number of Chinese nationals
entering is increasing,
the proportion of Chinese nationals has now become very high.
As of May this year,
Chinese tourists account for up to 33% of foreign tourists. Since
Chinese tourists
frequently undergo skin treatments when they visit the country, it
seems the expectation is to look forward to this aspect.  Below is the
quarterly export data for Gangneung City,
but the trend doesn't seem particularly positive
.  Since the second quarter of last year, there has
been no significant increase in exports, so the
growth rate of exports itself has
dropped considerably.  So,
since exports haven't fully picked up yet, I think we'll need to assess that
aspect in the second half of the year and next year
. However, I felt that it would be difficult to expect anything immediately
.
Now, following CEO Lee Seung-jun, I've popped up here
Now, there is a picture below; could you please explain the picture as well?
Uh, even so, I just gave it to you.  okay.
[Clears throat]
Now, I think the trend in spending by foreign medical tourists could become a
huge momentum for our domestic market.
Yesterday, when I was giving a
recent stock lecture or explanation, I
thought I would never invest in domestic distribution again in my life, but the number of
foreign tourists has already exceeded 10 million even before June has ended
.   It
exceeded 10 million people, and
when it saw a surge in 2019, it was just over 19 million.
Usually, one of the most important terms when trading stocks is
structural growth versus whether it is
structurally shifting into a bear market.
Regarding the retail sector, I believe it has
shifted into a structural bear market,
so I won't be looking at it going forward.  yes.
Companies in the online sector are stuck in a dead end due to distribution channels like Amazon and Coupang; they
can't do anything about it. If they don't renovate, they look even worse, so if you
look at department stores in Gangnam, entire ones are
now completely empty and failing.
So, even if we successfully completed the renovation,
customers would just come and window shop.
Since we were in a dead end where everyone was placing orders through electronic voting, I
thought there wouldn't be anything to do.
However, as tourists started flocking in and
consumption began, a huge amount of people are
coming in.  If you look at it, there are about 2.6 million Chinese tourists and
1.6 million Japanese tourists.
But if you ask if that is the end, the
tourism plan is moving towards an era of 30 million tourists
.  If it goes from 20 million to 30 million
won, it is
worth betting on.
So, if you look at the charts for department stores
recently—including Shinsegae Department Store—you
can see a fairly strong upward trend. Although there is
n't much talk about this sector yet, it appears to be undergoing a
structural growth turnaround
. However, people usually say that investing in turnaround stocks is difficult.  yes.  Peter Inch has
invested well even in turnaround stocks, so looking at the stock volume, I think the
turnaround has
begun in this sector.  It seems the key to the momentum of that turnaround is the
health factor that is coming in like a rush
.  Here is the performance
estimate table, so the
performance comes out as numbers, right?
yes.  Whether it comes out in numbers will likely be
revealed for each cyclical performance.
So, if the top line increases and
competition intensifies, the
profit margin won't be able to go up even if the top line grows.  Top line
increases, and profits increase together.
Ultimately, the stock price will
enter a phase where it turns around again, but I do
n't have time to explain.  It’s to the point where it needs to be done right away
. If you
look at the content of this report, actually, it’s
a bit of a stretch to say "right away"—well, the
content isn't really like that—but it
seems like the researchers are enjoying using interesting titles these days.  People
use Mimi and things like that a lot these days, and I got hooked by the title of that post, so I
clicked on it right away to read it.  hmm.
But [clears throat] the content was
n't much different from the previously released reports
.
What do you think about this, Dr. Wang?   I told you that
last time.   yes
.
Taking a plane from Korea
. Ah, yes, yes.   Even if you
come to Korea, stay in a hotel, and
do luxury shopping, it is actually better than living in China
.
yes.  wow.
Because it's coming too much only these days
.  Many of those managers are coming
.  You used to get dropped off in Hong Kong or China and come back to do tours
here and there. When I was doing
Samsung Electronics or NikEx, I did tours, and there were really a
lot of them. These days, I
think it's understandable that you might not know much, and the cost-effectiveness is killer right now. Also,
applying for the PVisa for going to Japan has become really expensive.   I'm
going to increase the price by about five times
.
Wow,
yes, so I
think it's much better that they're coming from here. And well, the peak
season is almost the time of summer break, isn't it? Since it's summer break, a
lot of large shrimp are coming in, so I think there's a
possibility that they'll receive a lot of attention and even reach their faces. It's
better to look at it from your perspective.  Everything is done.
Anyway, I
also checked the distance related to Baehwajeon.
Well, well, I don't like North Korea.
Most of them might turn out to be at the level of treasures,
and additionally, regarding the Ssambungi,
there is also a possibility that the actual performance will trend upward.   is it so
.   yes
.
Originally, the top part is a bit unripe.   yes
.  However, recently, companies have gained a lot of confidence because the sales from the department store
Yonsei Store could continue to exceed expectations
.  No, it’s not good for the third game either
.   It's
good, too.  yes.
So, looking at the seasonality of the performance, based on
past examples, the first quarter is
good and the fourth quarter is good.   yes
.  2 and 3 weren't good.   From the
perspective of the people with identity.  But when I
looked into why that might be, it
seems like it is a time when many people travel abroad.   The
game.  Ah, yes.
I [clear my throat] go a lot
.  yes.  yes.  That's right.  But
now that the exchange rate is high, it
seems like people won't travel abroad as much as they used to.  So,
if you look at the recent reports, the estimates for the second and
third quarters were significantly lower, but now
there is talk that, "Oh, it looks like it might turn out better than expected compared to condensers."
So, it seems that such a phenomenon exists
.  On top of that, there is also the effect of tourists,
right?  yes.
And
one of the reasons I trusted department stores earlier was who would be doing the
spending.
Our country's population structure is currently
becoming like an inverted triangle.
Then, as the population ages,
do people go to department stores to spend money?  no.  My
parents felt the same way,
so looking at the demographic structure, we
thought there was no solution for domestic distribution. However, as
foreigners began to flock in and start consuming, and stock
prices rose sharply like that, you can
simply use the flow to figure out what the next step is
.  Now, next is the Lee Yeon-taek
draft material,
titled "
SCA and CakePay Revealed by Alpha Micron Can Be
Trusted."   yes
.  What story?   If we
take a look at the details, you mentioned that this happened after the land flash foam
bent, so you
shared your personal experience
.  It is said that
before working as an analyst at a securities firm research center, he worked for about
three years in the overseas sales team of the semiconductor components division
.  When I first joined, Kyungwon, yes, yes
.   I
heard that when I first joined, the Land Flash was just starting to go out, and the inventory was so full it spilled over the warehouse and even filled the parking lot and cleanroom.  One day,
the head of overseas sales reportedly ordered that
all shipments, including those for which customers had already requested a suspension of transport, be added to cargo planes. This was
because, if the products were not transported, they would not be recognized as revenue, making a significant blow to the company inevitable.  They say that
all the
products were sent to the airport by that evening like a secret operation, and that some major chaos ensued as the Mugo liquids
confirmed the facts upon arrival at work
.   While
practices may change now, I
think the fact that the power of verbal promises or long-term contracts weakens rapidly once the badosi cycle breaks will not be much different.  Eventually, as the original learning
deteriorated, it is said that there was no such thing as loyalty in the Jianghu
.  However, they say
there is a customary sharing of responsibility.  It
is not that the client company is completely pretending not to know; while it is
easy to assume that production begins only after a customer places an order, the reality on the ground is
said to be not that simple.  They say it is because they need to secure parts or materials
in advance
.  And it is said that predictive production to some extent is inevitable
in order to improve process stability and reach Wednesday
.  They say the actual flow is roughly like this, but
first,
there is a forecast that the client will likely use this amount.
In other words, annual or quarterly demand forecasts are
provided to semiconductor companies, and
based on this, the semiconductor companies
secure raw materials or components in advance and
begin preparations for some production.   They say that
this isn't a big problem when the fish tank is doing well, but
issues start to arise when the cycle goes awry
.  The situation becomes even more serious, especially if the
model is discontinued or end demand
drops drastically
.  They say that while regular stock will
only be provided as additional support and may eventually be sold, the
stock for specific models will simply
become obsolete inventory.  It is
said that this often leads to a situation where the inventory must be disposed of at a bargain price, and that there are many cases where losses are incurred in the process.  However, they say that client companies do
not completely ignore this situation either
.  It is said that while there may
be differences depending on the reform conditions and bargaining power, there were cases where partial compensation was
provided to customers or losses were covered by future orders
.   There was
talk about SCA in Micron's recent earnings announcement, you know.
Micron's SCA and Take-Haul
Pain this time can be seen as a structure one step stronger than before,
and it is
said that the SA appears to be a more binding contract than the existing LTA.  It can be viewed as a structure where the customer does not
simply provide quests,
but promises to purchase a specific quantity over a fixed period, with even the
minimum cancellation price reflected in the contract
.  The key point here is the inclusion of a take-all pay
clause, which states that,
in principle, a certain amount
must be paid even if the promised quantity is not actually taken.
So, Micro stated that the
minimum emissions over the contract period of the 14 SCAs are at
the level of about $100 billion
.  There are a total of 16 SCAs, and simply put, the
annual scale is estimated to be over $20 billion
. It is said that this accounts for
about 20% of the annual deal volume and about
30% of the land volume.  What is particularly important is the take-back
clause, as it is
said that it has become difficult to unilaterally shift risk to the supplier using the method of delaying recapture because demand has decreased, as was done in the past.  So,
the interpretation is that while it is not entirely new, it can be seen as a meaningful change.  In the past, there have been processes where customers
bore scrap risks or some inventory losses
.  However, it is said that this
SCA and take-home pay are
seen as contracts that go beyond that level.   The
opinion is that this seems somewhat significant in that customers have started to share the long-term risks of memory prices and volume, rather than simply being partially compensated for bad inventory.
From the perspective of visible memory manufacturers like Micron, Hynix, and Samsung Electronics, this can be seen as a much more favorable contract structure than in the past
.  Of course, I explained that we would have to wait and see how strongly binding
these contracts actually are even when the final cycle collapses,
but I also stated that,
so far, it seems clear that the structure of the memory industry is
shifting in a direction much more favorable to suppliers than in the past
.
So, regarding the story about SC Take-All Pay that the Vice President mentioned after Micron's earnings announcement yesterday,
[snorting] Researcher Lee Yun-taek, as well as other
semiconductor analysts,
left various comments.   It
seems like we are generally talking about similar things. Hmm,
looking at the table below, it looks like they
brought in a graph of Hynix's operating profit margin for four quarters, and it starts
from 2010. That is
correct.  And the English proficiency rate
recorded a negative figure not only in '23 but also in
.
Hynix was acquired by SK Telecom in
November 2011,
but the
operating profit margin was in the red
.  A somewhat bad look back then.
Around 2010 and 2011, Elpida and
Infinum went bankrupt, and it was a time when the
final, harsh restructuring of the semiconductor memory industry was taking place.
After that, once the market became oligopolistic,
SK, whose operating profit rarely fell into the red, was a masterstroke at the time.
Since LG was formed by merging LG Semiconductor and Hyundai Semiconductor, whenever there was
talk that LG Electronics might acquire it, LG Electronics' stock
price would plummet. Consequently, whenever
such talk arose, the LG Group adamantly insisted, "
We will not buy it."  Then suddenly,
SK Telecom buys it.  I
remember buying it for about 3 trillion back then, but now there is
talk of it reaching 300 trillion or 500 trillion next year,
so it turned out to be a masterstroke.
Okay, by the way, Senior Officer Lee Yeon-tae always captures the data in such an
interesting way. Wow,
things like this really did happen back when I worked in semiconductor sales
.   yes
.   It was
shipped out by cargo plane without any conditions before the customer arrived, so it has already been dispatched.
yes.   Not
only this, but
there are also semiconductor distribution companies in the middle.  So, memory
manufacturers
had distribution companies in front of Samsung, and in
order to control sales or similar factors,
there are cases where they push products to distributors before reaching the client.   There were times when people would say, "
Hey, take this," and as
business deteriorated, there was
no such thing as the loyalty of the martial arts world.   It is
set up like this, but anyway, it is telling us about the changed
status.
you're right.
Among our company's clients, there is an executive from the electronics industry who told me
an anecdote last time, saying that
Tim Cook got very annoyed and said that Mars did it
.   We have been
big customers all this time, but
you guys have cut us down on the price so much that we
won't accept anything other than this price.   I
mentioned an episode where he got extremely annoyed because of this topic. It’s
not just about how to trade stocks easily; I engage in power dynamics
. I ask myself, "Is the subordinate
now the superior?" I
sell when the subordinate is in a position of power, and I sell when they are no longer in that position.
So now, regarding Micron Synex and
Samsung Electronics, it is said that
their status has completely changed. Regarding what you said,
Chairman Lee Jae-yong's status has
changed.  Today, the person in charge
spoke to the Apple team in one word: "
Yeah,
you guys tore down our unit prices when we were struggling, so
we almost starved to death."
Oh, I did.
They always think about the best last one, but it was
difficult for us to invest as well.  I'm talking about it.
So, that means I’ve reached a
position where I can say things like that.
Hey, if it
breaks later, Micro is dead.
Now [laughs]
uh, as you get older, you end up really
keeping this inside
.
[Laughs]
So I should be careful with my words.
Uh, you should be careful with your words.  But isn't the team changed
?   It
has been replaced.  yes.
Ah, it was replaced,
and the new person
must have heard about Micron just now as well.   Right
?   This
is good news for Samsung Electronics and Hynix.   From what I
see.
[Laughs]
Looking at the table on the right, it's Ebi and
Evitich. This Micron
is trading at about 50% of the level of Hynix.  It is still like that even now
.   yes
.  Based on EBITDA, or rather,
based on PR, it
trades at about 30% or 40%, though I
don't think it's quite 40% or 40%; it
dropped about ten to nine times.
Ah, up to nine times. Yes, it dropped by about nine times. With this pass being
adjusted significantly upward, it
fell by about 20%. Yes, about 20%. Here, it looks like the blue is Samsung, the
center color is Hynix, and the black is
Micron. Yes, that is
correct.
Yes, so based on the EB Evitt, it's
7.4 times,
Hynix is ​​5.2 times, and the cube is 4 times—
things like that.
Yes,
the side I don't look at often.  yes.  Anyway, I guess I have to bet a
high price on that.
All right.
Okay, I have to connect to
Korea Economic TV in a little while, starting at 9:35.
[Clears throat] They
went in to prepare the final material, so you can
watch it in a moment.
Uh, that is the main point.
Looking at the chart for cap small-cap stocks, they have been down 10.7% since the beginning of the year
.  Ah,
and KOSDAQ -4%, no
surprise.   hmm.
The chart for that large-cap stock had surpassed ten thousand.   hmm.
One of the causes of this discrimination is that,
ultimately, the
central global central government is
shifting its policies toward austerity, and
these factors are having an impact.
Furthermore, the
internal structure of the "Kevin Clothes" (referring to a specific stock) has undergone a short-term transformation.
Looking at past examples of such changes, the question is
how this will
affect the stock market, and that is what is currently having an impact
.   I’m thinking of
explaining that part a little later.
How is the market
doing?  How did the night gift session
end yesterday?
Micron surged 15%, but
that was a preemptive strike in our market.
So, MSSI South Korea
Eft rose 4%, but the night shift
started in the negative at -1.45%. Yes, it
opened down -1.31%.  It
is currently -1.8%.  It is 1.8%.
What is happening with the 1.8% KOSDAQ?  yes.   The
KOSDAQ started down 0.38%
.  Current -2.24%.   hmm.
It appears in Section Chief Oh's materials as well.  KOSPI at
200 won, up 139.9% and 140% this year,
KOSPI up 111%, and KOSDAQ in the
negative.
Now, regarding
today's questions, I saw earlier that there was a question about whether it is
possible to reach 10,000 points in July. Well,
tonight in the US market,
since
both plus and plus were expected to go plus,
it was minus minus.
That SP was minus minus, but since it dropped by 0.01%, it was
practically right next to it.   yes
.
Ah, but
put in a little too much, 0.01.   It
appears that the index fell significantly because big tech stocks dropped quite a bit.   Because the market
capitalization is large.
So,
actually, today too... um.  The Philban keeps rising, though it
went up by about 3%.   yes
.  Since Nasdaq and SB have a large
weighting of big tech companies, they have
fallen significantly, so I think they will likely come back up, but it
looks like they will continue to drop until today.  [Laughs] I
hope it goes up.   It
looks like the Nasdaq will continue to see some correction until today.
Go Ja
Paul, yes, yes.
Our Vice President Choi's baptismal name is
Paul, right? Yes, Paul.
Paul is Phil, and Philban is also yes.
Philban is
Philadelphia, right?
Yes, I
think that kind of regular juice will be omitted. Right now, yes, I
want to because an important event has finished.  습니다.   I
think it's a coffin where it wouldn't be too strange to take a break.   The
important thing is that this is just a temporary pause, so I do
n't think the correction is severe enough to warrant selling here and buying back down later.
So, you're expecting a
sideways adjustment as well
?  Yes, that is correct.
Also, since
previews of the second-quarter earnings announcements may
come out, I think there will be some issues then that
could drive the market more seriously.
Currently,
interest in Micron is very strong,
and the impact is so massive that I
think the price has already been fully reflected.   I
think there might be a brief break.
So, at this point, I think people might
feel a bit of a urge to realize profits
.
yes.  So, it seems like it will drop a bit.
yes.
Now, it looks like the US market—whether it's the SP 500,
Nasdaq, or the general market—will undergo some correction
.
When the US undergoes a correction and our market drops today, it
becomes a bit tricky to place a shot, thinking, "Ah, the US will rise tonight anyway." But the
KOSDAQ is showing another bearish candle.   yes
.  This is a bearish candle on the KOSDAQ.
How did you do yesterday?
Yesterday's candle is bearish.
Uh, it was a bearish candle yesterday.  You're right.
Well, the KOSPI
opened yesterday with a bullish candle, as expected.  yes.
Hey, yesterday the opening price
was shaking a bit right after it started,
[clears throat] but today the market is
completely wrecked, even for materials, parts, and equipment, so
everything is dropping.  There are many people who have missed out, but since
Micron's short-term earnings momentum has ended and the
stock price already reflected that yesterday, and given that
today is Friday, I
think there is a higher possibility of a bearish candle today.
Oh, come to think of it, today is Friday.
Today, the
KOSPI is
expected to rise with a bearish candle.
Uh, as I mentioned the other day, the
market [clears throat] right now,
psychologically speaking, the overall market
atmosphere is... well, I mean, a pharmacy school atmosphere. And because of that,
[snorting] if you
look at the COVID era, at first, there was a "
Big Say" where
only specific large-cap stocks went up first.
Because, with the occurrence of the COVID-19 situation, the
overall economy and
investment sentiment have weakened.
However, since liquidity
creates the central bank's interest rate,
money is abundant. Yet, since it is obvious that
corporate sales will plummet in a situation like COVID-19, investors tend to
focus intensively on only those companies that can generate profits.   Is that so
?  It becomes rare.  Since
companies making money are
scarce in situations like COVID-19, there is a phenomenon where large-cap stocks in sectors such as BBIJ,
biotech, batteries, the internet, and games are
particularly seeing a surge in their prices.
Currently,
interest rates are still
moving at a relatively high level, and
banks are shifting toward a stance of raising interest rates
.  Because they want to,
so companies with weaker stamina... Yes, that is correct.   The
stock prices of such companies have been falling significantly recently, and based on my
forecast, I expect interest rates to drop in the second half of the year
.
Interest rates actually started to fall again around August and September
.  The CPI is falling, so... well, regarding
this correction, I'll conclude that this could also be an opportunity to buy stocks cheaply. I'll explain that later. You
mentioned investor sentiment a little while ago, and
among the indicators I check every day is
PN Green Nex. I
noticed today that it has entered an extreme fear zone
.
Ah, it dropped below 25
.  yes.
yes.  So, even if we look at
the data we present on the first page this morning, we are
actually observing signs that the stronghold of Big Tech is
crumbling a bit.
Especially as they
enter into a CAPEX competition, it is
true that concerns exist regarding how long they can continue to pursue such aggressive CAPEX strategies.
And there are concerns that if other companies also engage in
CAPEX, their earnings might actually
worsen, and it
seems that this atmosphere itself is affecting investor sentiment to some extent.   I
suppose so.
yes.
All right.  Okay, it's Friday.  Oh,
you worked hard this week, and June is
almost over?  I went out.
yes.  There is nothing left.
Also, regarding the weakness of our domestic market, are you
a bit of a beginner because of the ridiculous soccer loss yesterday
?
Isn't it slightly affected?  It's a bit anticlimactic.  That's right.
Have a great weekend, and
tomorrow at Byeolju Bujeon, Yuri Pro and I
will take some time to review the week's market.
yes.  That concludes today's Chaeslim Moin Brief for June
26.
Thank you.